at the start of the movie A group of
kids Venture into a forbidden cave to
conduct research 10 minutes later they
noticed something horrifying so one of
the girls decides to get out and call
for help surprisingly when she reaches
the top she finds out that Earth has
completely changed there are massive
rock formations sandstorms are wreaking
havoc everywhere and even a spaceship is
seen in the vicinity this implies that
somehow over 1 000 years have passed
outside the cave while they've been
inside the movie then flashes back to
how it all started archeology Professor
Hopper along with his dog boss are
searching nearby the isolated system of
caves they come across a van which
apparently belonged to the 70s it turns
out Hopper is searching for a group of
hippies that went missing decades ago
and the minivan belonged to them they're
probably out eating sandwiches and
hunting ghosts as the search continues
boss starts barking as if he has sensed
something and wants to go home
immediately however disregarding his
wishes Hopper enters one of the caves
and discovers a strange Cowboy Frozen in
in time the man appears to be from a
different era which is evident from his
clothing and gun taken aback Hopper gets
back in his car and drives back home
there he is greeted by his two students
Taylor and Jackie who are excited to
start their new exploration trip but to
their dismay Hopper tells them that the
plan has changed so he will be going
alone now shortly after he gathers all
the necessary items and gets back to the
cave there he discovers a strange Lair
that separates the atmosphere between
the outside world and the cave although
skeptical Hopper enters the lair and as
soon as he does so the Frozen man starts
moving in the next scene it has been two
days since the students heard from their
Professor so they decide to look for him
but since they don't own a vehicle
Taylor is forced to ask for help from a
girl named Cara who has a massive crush
on him Cara immediately agrees to bring
her dad's Jeep but only if she and her
little sister Vives are also allowed to
join in to make matters worse the
archeology students are compelled to
take another kid Furby with them Furby
as he and thieves are apparently
shooting for their school project after
a while the group arrives at the spot
and discovers the abandoned minivan from
before on checking they learned that the
hippies the professor was looking for
are none other than his parents they
ventured into the system of caves some
decades back in search of the Fountain
of Youth but never returned then they
discover a worn out rope that leads them
to a different part of the cave Jackie
follows the Rope through a slender
tunnel and finds out that it has been
cut off she also notices that the cave
goes very deep and it is possibly where
the professor has been lost Taylor
asserts that the Rope is too old to
belong to Professor Hopper but he
nonetheless decides to get down and
inspect the Cave the girls also decide
to join him while Furby is ordered to
keep watch as he is too scared of the
dark come on Furby grow a pair while
climbing down the massive cave Cara
comes across the same strange barrier
and informs Taylor that the temperature
is different on either side of it
despite this they carry on with their
descent until they finally reach the
base of the cave following this the
movie Cuts back to two days ago when
Professor Hopper has just entered the
barrier as he is slowly making his way
through the cave suddenly he hears a
scream from inside followed by a
terrifying howl alarmed Hopper starts
running back and reaches the entrance
where he notices the sunlight flickering
in a strange manner when he finally gets
outside it's already night time despite
him having been in the cave for merely
two minutes he then hurries to his truck
but finds that it has been covered by
overgrown plants in fact the whole area
which was once a desert has been covered
by dense forest implying that decades
have passed since Hopper entered the
mysterious cave shortly after he comes
across Kara's dilapidated Jeep and
Taylor's backpack so he decides to get
back into the cave to look for them back
in the present the group explores the
cave until they hear the same terrifying
howl that Hopper heard earlier scared
that something is lurking in the dark
they decide to abandon their mission and
head home Jackie goes first and as she
is climbing the Rope is suddenly cut
causing her to fall from a decent hide
as a result she fractures her leg while
Taylor who is trying to save her breaks
his arm then Taylor tries to check on
the second rope but surprises it has
been cut as well with this they deduced
that Furby has been messing around with
them an angry tailor tries calling him
from the radio but the boy doesn't reply
by this time the group has started
panicking and as they are brainstorming
ideas to get out of the cave a loud thud
is heard in the background it appears as
if something fell from above scared
Taylor again tries to make contact via
the radio and this time a muffled voice
replies help me Taylor asks about the
man's identity and to everyone's horror
it turns out to be Furby when I was a
kid Furby scared the [ __ ] out of me too
left with no options the group decides
to venture further into the tunnel until
they come across a place where the sky
is visible surprisingly just like Hopper
had witnessed earlier the Sun keeps
flickering continuously as if day is
turning into night in the fraction of a
second but despite this the genius
Taylor believes that Furby is playing
another prank on them with his
flashlight oh okay Taylor sure buddy
however to their horror when they
continue inspecting the place they find
Furby lying dead on the side his neck
has been broken and some nasty marks are
visible on his face the site devastates
the group and they start fearing that
someone is after them when Taylor finds
Furby's cut off rope they become sure of
it fortunately the group finds the
little boy's GoPro still in working
condition and decides to check what
caused his demise in the video Furby is
waiting for the group to return for days
but to no avail he tries everything
calling them through the radio screaming
through every hole in the cave and even
throwing rocks for a hint but never gets
any response when he gets bored he
wanders through the nearby area and
comes across the hippies minivan from
the 70s which has a journal inside of it
the journal mentions that the mysterious
cave contains a fountain of youth which
can miraculously heal people or even
bring the dead back to life and this is
the reason why Hopper's parents went
into the cave as his mom was suffering
from a rare form of cancer a few more
days pass by and Furby has exhausted all
his food and water supply assuming that
his friends are dead he decides to leave
the place but for that he needs the Jeep
keys from Taylor hence he decides to
climb down into the k cave and retrieve
them himself but when he crosses the
mysterious barrier he notices the sky
changing rapidly before he can make
sense of the phenomenon the Rope snaps
automatically resulting in a deadly fall
this is the thud the group heard earlier
once inside the Cave the radio starts
working so an injured Furby tries
calling out for help but unfortunately
this only draws the attention of some
man-eaters who arrive there and kill him
mercilessly the footage leaves the group
in a State of Shock confusion and
sadness they're perplexed as to how
Furby spent days outside while it has
only been 30 minutes for them inside the
cave now the group is desperate to get
out of the place since Cara is the only
one who is fit and not injured she is
tasked with free climbing her way out of
the massive cave before leaving Taylor
hands her a beacon so that she can alert
the authorities as soon as she gets a
signal after a bit of a struggle Kara
finally gets out of the cave but what
she notices leaves her dumbfounded the
area which was once covered with dense
Green Forest has turned into an
uninhabitable Barren land with
sandstorms brewing in the distance the
oxygen supply is also very low because
of which Cara keeps on coughing scared
she climbs up to a rock and tries to get
a signal on the beacon as expected Kara
does not get any signal but she notices
a strange spaceship like object floating
in the distance indicating that the time
is moved on by several Millennia when
she gets back into the cave Taylor and
the others are upset that she didn't
even try it turns out that while Cara
was outside for a Whole 30 minutes only
a few seconds have passed for the group
inside the cave enraged that her efforts
are not being appreciated Cara shows her
camera which verifies her claim that she
did in fact go outside in the video the
strange deserted world and the massive
sandstorms are all visible finally
Taylor deduces that for some reason the
time inside the cave is slowed down and
every time the sun flickers it means
that one day has passed finally about
time these noobs figured that out he
adds that this is the reason why the
ropes were being cut off as the friction
over the years made them fragile oh I
hadn't figured that out hearing all this
Vives decides to re-watch Furby's
footage once again and when she does she
discover something shocking in one of
the frames the sky is changing its color
with the dark sky being the winter and
the light one summer this concludes that
every second inside the cave is not a
day outside but in fact an entire year
the Revelation terrifies the group and
they become even more desperate to
escape once Kara gains her energy back
she again attempts to get out of the
cave but just then a futuristic looking
ladder is thrown in out of nowhere then
a giant alien-like figure starts
climbing down prompting everyone to back
off when the alien reaches the cave
suddenly a barbaric man-eater attacks
him a fight and sees between the two but
the giant alien easily subdues and ties
up the man-eater with a high-end
electronic device then he starts going
after the group causing them to flee in
Terror after a while Taylor and the Gang
arrive at a mysterious place where a
group of man-eaters are devouring their
recent victim it appears to be the same
Cowboy from the start of the movie
unfortunately the man-eaters notice the
humans and begin chasing after them in
order to buy others time to flee Taylor
makes the ultimate sack sacrifice and
fights the beasts alone sadly he is of
no match and the man-eaters brutally
finish him off once they leave the place
to chase after the others Kara sneaks
inside and is devastated to see Taylor
laying dead as she weeps in despair the
giant alien approaches the two and drags
Taylor to a small pool of water which
appears to be the Fountain of Youth lo
and behold he comes back to life and the
myth which was always laughed at by
others turns out to be real but before
the group can Rejoice the man haters
return and start attacking the giant
this time they outnumber him and even
manage to take his helmet off which
leaves the giant gasping for air luckily
before he can be finished off Kara and
Taylor help him out and eventually trap
the man-eaters with his equipment after
the altercation the couple tries to help
the giant up to his feet but they fail
it appears as if the oxygen inside the
Earth's atmosphere is poisonous for him
causing his internal organs to fail at
the same time thieves and Jackie also
arrive there and notice the devastation
lying around before dying the giant
displays a news report about the group's
disappearance from several Millennia ago
he also shows the many other Clips which
indicate that the living conditions on
earth have become uninhabitable so the
humans have left for another planet a
special spaceship called The Ark is
responsible for transporting the humans
and it is the same object that Kara had
seen earlier after providing all this
information the giant passes away in the
next scene as Taylor searches the cave
for more clues he suddenly comes across
Professor Hopper lying injured on the
floor but what he sees next shocks him
to the core in front of him are several
other layers of time which move at even
slower rates in the first layer Hopper's
parents are frozen while in deeper
layers several prehistoric men are
fighting one another to seize the
Fountain of Youth Hopper then explains
that the whole system of caves is
designed to keep humans out and other
organisms from using the Fountain of
Youth Taylor tries to escort him back to
safety but Hopper insists on staying
there shortly after Taylor returns back
to his group and puts the dead Furby
into the Fountain of Youth Jackie also
heals her injured leg there but just as
they are about to leave the barbarians
again surround them with nowhere to get
go the group decides to use the
high-tech ladder from the alien Kara
goes first but when she reaches the top
she finds out that the entrance has been
filled with water suddenly a creature
Yanks her up much to the horror of the
remaining group now Taylor and the
others are in a perilous situation if
they go up the creatures will kill them
but if they back down the barbarians
will eat them a few seconds later a
fully transformed Cara returns to the
cave and pulls everyone with a high-tech
rope a while later she also pulls Furby
Professor Hopper and his parents it
turns out that the creatures that pulled
Cara earlier are actually human beings
that evolved with the change of time and
despite Kara having been gone for mere
seconds in the cave she in fact lived
several years outside in the final scene
the group is brought to the ark which is
on its course to look for a new planet
to live in the ark is being controlled
by evolved creatures who speak a
completely different language the movie
ends as the spaceship blasts into space
leaving the Blue Planet behind forever
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notification locations and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching